pode estar na minha vida fazer isso tem
muita gente achando gorda em sua mistura
do café na mentira na ag solve quem fala
é o dark muito bem vindos
haia 16 eu estraguei mais um vídeo do
microscópio microscópios nós temos
observado uma caixa cheia de barata e
estes não são daquelas eventuais pontos
de encontro em vossa casa nené esses
braços estão lra quickscan baratas em 8
foi de 1 128 e 121 para receber
lançamento medo imagina a barata 25 o
assunto mas não lê
eu tentei cruzar os braços para
conseguir separar microscópios e ea
psicóloga e elas têm a 2000 ela é barata
empenhada no mar que tinham fugido foi
parar embaixo da cama de mel ela vai pôr
muito ovo muito filho lá debaixo da cama
portanto nós temos que destruir a casa
então o que aconteceu o que eu tenho
aqui mais para ver só rolar uma caixa
cheia de larvas
olha aí pelo menos esta possa abrir é
porque olha só eu ou não bom e nem fazem
falta mas não só de alagoas ainda não
estou dizendo ser ele ou grupal e porque
quem está aqui por 48 ou comprar um
segundo ele mais novos lagares e então
os lagartos alimentam o texto portanto
eu antes de escolherem tudo é bom
observar o microscópio né
antes morriam todos da nike uma caixa
com aranhas com ela veste povos ming ano
vamos falar de outra coisa é tão inócuas
da agu não olha só que maravilha que não
só os confunde com um vídeo vamos tentar
atingir uma meta é buscar atendimento
estudantil likes no exterior que não
chegaram aos 20 milagres eu vou eu vou
buscar uma coisa ainda mais nojento do
que estudar aqui junto eu sei que vocês
estão curiosos mas por vender é ok vamos
começar então por ver que os mops larvas
que quer coisa mais lendo aqui olha eu
vou parar numa coxa
deu é modelo não deu para você vai voar
mas que em 321 ai ai meu deus usa muito
orgulho muito grande ter som muitas dá
pra mim tudo olha só textura meu elas
têm que colocar a pasta bem dura e isso
aqui para haia que quer um cineasta não
gostou muito juntinhos
houve um rabo de uma lei lei que eu
estou fazendo de tudo juntos
eu acho que estão todos à procura de
comida porque tentar encontrar a cabeça
do meu quero muito ver na cabeça de uma
das que são calmas que são as questões
que outras mães bem claro e outra vez
cura há nelas anc lei isso aqui costuma
ver só isso aqui é pelo pelas larvas que
elas mudam papel aqui como podem ver
isso aqui é um papel do água é mesmo
olha só a cabeça dela lei essa que possa
responder uma bela pouco tempo eu acho
que é isso aí bem escura essa tem doença
no estado barata barata do esgoto ok vou
tentar esmagar que o mas vamos ver como
é que o vice dela no ou aqui dá prazer
muito pro nole vejam só como ela está
suja com coisas branquíssima eu acho que
encontrar a cabeça
olha só a cabeça dela 22 min antenas ela
é muito linda olha aí tinha dela tem
muita pata qualquer próxima coisa que
nós vamos ver vamos firme nox minhoca
d'água olha só a minhoca nem estranho e
olha lá 321 vai minhoca de água mas o
que isto falei que os seus misteriosos
do lago que os lados lado estados unidos
em 1980 isso que pretendemos marinhos
muito bem não só tem nessas pata pata o
estresse um olho e toda pra mim tá aqui
ações dentro dela não está um monstro é
um monstro mas nem só de mim o canal
estava muito grande até para eu preciso
mais perto é voltar de uma colher já
tenho mas é o primeiro óbito na bola só
minhoca en 321 my soul recusando china
que tavira foi estranho eu sei que tem
muita textura do povo que fazer aquela
lua carinho em que isto são patas meu
aqui da primeira parte de muito perto e
vou tentar virar a cabeça dela embora lá
31 vai muito estranho e um povo
eu acho que o estômago quando passa a
comida dentro dela além do pessoal e sem
cabeça da nossa minhoca mel e uma boca
gigante com dentes nem escrever em caixa
alta
acho que vou conseguir ver as patas da
uaç quatro delas são espinhos dois
filhos da pátria deste ano é que os
bichos não é assim tão fácil mas quando
chegava em casa quanto é muito fácil
mesmo que tem muita passa muito tempo
muita boca muito tudo eu acho que elas
morreram junto juntos concluiu muito mal
para a próxima coisa que nós vamos ver
vai ser o único dia em média
aqui dentro é que existe vai passear
pelo jardim e encontrei uma tela gigante
de energia antes mesmo de lá dentro
tinha sexto ninhos de urânio que de mim
e aranha leva mais ou menos uns 50 ovos
muito pop rock fica ouvindo destinasse
maranhão eu não fiz o mesmo vinhos mais
que mexam em snatch isso é muito cedo e
eu já tenho um pouquinho mais ou menos a
quatro dias 45 dias eo até hoje não abre
portas mas não ser uma surpresa aqui né
isso que eu digo isto porque eu acho que
a cena já nasceram e os para imagens em
crise e pichadas com o quinho com o
calor com oxigênio porque eu fui caixa e
eu acho que obedeça tampinha vou física
que minta gêmeas bebês têm muitas vezes
não tem falta que eles estão sete
minutos diante porque não se quer
nenhuma 50 anos b e agora imaginem 7 50
eu não sei fazer contas faça vocês é
muita areia e uma entrevista aqui com
vocês e eu não sei o que vai acontecer
mas vamos falar 321 vai eu vou tentar me
expressar e mostrar vos que vai
acontecer rápido não é muito rock elas
são tão pequenas como a prevista tipo
mesmo só com o eu vou tentar apontar
microscópio então embora lá risos mas eu
vou tentar só contar um pouco sobre o
filme maranhão ok só voltar a abrir a
caixa e enfiar sólidos com aquilo que
dentro não quer sair antes que eu só
quero ver isso ao microscópio boatos um
paywall holley
nb desde o som de vocês conseguem ver o
y lei podem continuar são muitas
eu mesmo em madrid me tamanha que ela
tinha muito pelo só vou tentar esticar
para aqui olha ela bateu a grega para
contar-lhe trevas todas as ruas são
muitas leis são muitas são muitas vezes
conseguem ver mas tem que uma duas três
quatro cinco anos a tentar fugir a ela
está a fugir muito ela só sai da
campanha olha aí meu é muito que o diz é
muito fofa que só chega de aranha depois
toda a forma e agora vem a parte mais
nojenta muito nojento que é barata as
nossas meninas na amiga não é barata
asiática 2 mostrou muito centrada barato
aí essa barata e tem o tamanho da minha
boca aí é igual e vou tentar e brilho e
vocês vão ver de perto aí por favor não
fugir muito grande e supostamente ela
saltou que você tentar ficar no more bem
estranha dizer acabará se tem mais medo
do ser humano como ser humano é barata
mas mesmo aí para eu ouvir tudo a lei é
mais barato
luiz takaki quase impossível para tantos
que eu possa sentar na janela só aqui
com muito cuidado e vou tentar agarrar
bem grande
tentar fazer em microscópio lá dentro e
vamos ver como ela estava em r 31 vai tu
mesmo em cima das costas de uma bolha e
não é muito lindo quando a sua textura
da década passada ao ano no orçamento
das duas mãos ou aquelas metas nem
portanto estas tão bem em frente tem que
ter umas manchas e perder a cabeça dela
olha só esse equipamento não avançou
muito gostoso eu sou o antena 1
é muito louco olha só dela gigante sente
uma barata está virado ao contrário e
ela tem até tinha só eu vou tentar ver
de pertinho dela toca aí esta é parte
dela pessoal vejam só a quantidade de
espinhas que tem meu ex pm pelo telefone
pelo imagine é barata cada um é uma
palavra
agora só vou tentar agarrar uma comédia
eu vou conseguir
olha só a cães muito mesmo na minha vida
fazer isto tem muito cachorro e o tempo
dessa alma sem uma proteção explodir em
istambul em todas eu pego a minha casa
de cada bloco a sua textura dela meu
incrível morales cabeça da ex patroa
gente pinho smel aí agora eu saber
dúvida barriga dela mas acho que não vou
conseguir ver porque elas nunca como
barriga para cima a não ser quando
morrem eu vou deixar aqui a detinha o
melhor da taxa ptax a nós vamos ficar
por aqui com este vídeo porque já não
tem jeito pra mim hoje já gosto não só
mexer tá linda chega a minhoca podre e
vamos assumir o que não se quer que
fosse ela morreu toda hoje
agora morreu só apresentará que o cheiro
vem por néné perdida assim é e espero
que vocês tenham gostado né
só sabem como embaixo coisas que ver o
que eu vejo no microscópio que coisas do
dia-a-dia qualquer coisa como tem está
sabendo só vamos tentar atingir a meta
dos 200 mil sites por ouvir coisas tem
nada mais nojento do que barack baixos
vão poder ver vídeos que provavelmente
não viram o título mas vamos ver se
inscrever aqui no canal do taco prêmio é
gratuito portanto passam isso a partilha
com os votos de 2010 e que vai até a
próxima